[Music]
all right we'll get this suspense
through now welcome everyone to IO 302
optimizing performance on cloud sequel
for my sequel thanks for your patience
as we were getting started there my name
is Bret hesterberg I'm a product manager
at Google working on cloud sequel I'm
joined today by Stanley Feng and Ted
chaough
Stanley leads our storage and database
performing performance testing teams in
Google cloud and for those of you who
are familiar with the Linux ecosystem
Ted show may not need any introduction
Ted has been a longtime Linux
contributor and is currently an ext4
filesystem maintainer ext4 file system
will show up as an important point in
our discussion today before we jump in
we'd love to learn a little more about
you so by show of hands how many of you
out there are developers a good chunk of
the room okay how about DevOps engineers
a handful of DevOps engineers great how
many DBAs do we have out there database
administrators all right good to see
some hands going up how many reluctant
DBAs do we have out there Oh a few more
I'm not surprised and do we have any
managers in the audience oh yeah a few
few brave managers here good okay couple
more questions for you how many of you
attended Google cloud next last year in
2017 handful of folks and anyone in that
group attend to the cloud sequel
performance talk last year a Google
cloud next all right I think we've got a
group of first-timers for cloud sequel
performance performance thank you all
for joining us today let's talk a little
bit about what we're gonna cover and
actually before I do that let me just go
through just a few room logistics in
case you haven't been to a presentation
in a movie theater we have mics at the
front of the theater here that we'll use
for QA if you have questions please jot
them down as we go along we'd love to
get those addressed with the last five
to ten minutes or so of the presentation
we also have
we also have members of the cloud sequel
engineering team in the audience they're
sitting in one of the front rows here
they'll be available as will Stanley Ted
and myself after the talk to answer your
questions if you get a chance and you
have some questions I highly encourage
that you talked with the engineers the
folks who build the product and and
we'll get those addressed in one fashion
or another
okay with that what are we talking about
today we will start with a brief cloud
sequel introduction and then talk about
how to scale it up and scale it out from
there
we'll get into a bit more deeply
technical content and you'll see as we
go through the presentation today that
it gets progressively more technical
we'll take a look back to last year at
next we showed performance numbers last
year for cloud sequel and we'll talk
about how in the year that has passed
we've been able to increase cloud sequel
performance by around double and we'll
talk about the tuning parameters that
went into it and then we'll talk a bit
more about our future work here which
we're calling 16 kilobyte instance it's
a write optimization enhancement that's
required the work of many teams at
Google and Ted will be taking us through
that I I think it's a really interesting
topic for us to cover as cloud sequel
because cloud sequel first and foremost
makes sure that we prioritize data
integrity and we're gonna be turning off
as part of or at least talking about
turning off as part of this conversation
a feature in my sequel called
double right buffer and when you search
on that term what you'll find is that
most online conversations end with a
statement like don't turn that off if
you wish to maintain data integrity
we're gonna be talking about doing that
across our fleet and for all production
instances and I think it's gonna be an
interesting conversation for us to have
with you today as to why we think that's
safe and why we think it's the right
thing to do from a performance
standpoint okay let's jump in and let me
first start by pointing out where cloud
sequel is in the overall Google database
portfolio google has a fairly broad
portfolio as you can see on the slide
looking right most you see third party
or partner database offerings on Google
Cloud Google cloud generally has a large
partner ecosystem the list you see on
the rightmost side of the cloud is not
comprehensive there are many other there
are many other
sorry I having a little trouble with the
slides here there are many other partner
offerings on Google cloud if you look
leftmost on the slide you see the
in-memory databases we just recently
announced and a managed Redis service if
you have caching needs we do have more
offerings this year than we did last
year and you can expect generally the
portfolio the database portfolio to
continue to increase over time looking
just right of Center you see the
relational portion of a portfolio it's
made up of cloud spanner and cloud
sequel if you haven't checked out cloud
span or been to one of the talks at the
conference this week encourage you to do
so on spanner it's a great product to
get to know cloud sequel's role in the
in the portfolio is compatibility cloud
sequel is meant to offer very standard
my sequel and Postgres compatibility we
work hard to offer as close to unmanaged
my sequel and Postgres as we can so that
we can say if your application works
with my sequel or with Postgres it's
going to work with cloud sequel most of
our talk today will focus on my sequel
but will point out a few Postgres items
as well okay in addition to
compatibility cloud sequel aims to
reduce mundane database administration
that's often associated with running my
sequel in Postgres and as we we talk
through this I think pointing out what
mundane means is important when we talk
about things that are mundane we may
have to get a little tech help up here
looks like we've got slides that are
wanting to progress as a mind of their
own when we talk about mundane we think
about simple things like telling cloud
sequel watch how much storage I'm using
and as needed increase the amount of
storage so that I don't run out of it we
also talked about some advanced concepts
that we'll get into as I look at the
overall stack
okay we'll give it a shot here okay so I
think too when you think about cloud
sequel Tim Kelton from decart labs does
a pretty good job of summing it up he
says cloud sequel gives his team more
time to work on products or more time to
work on things other than database
administration that are valuable to his
customers and it's a good way to think
about cloud sequel when I think about
cloud sequel I tend to picture this
stack this stack shows a few different
columns leftmost okay leftmost is a
stack representing hardware these are
servers that you're racking and stacking
worrying about heating and cooling for
example in addition to this stack as you
move right on the slide we start to
think about the operating system that
must be it must be run on the server's
themselves and keeping that operating
system up-to-date moving further right
we finally start to talk about databases
this is the database installation it's
software patching on the database
keeping it secure and mandatory things
like making sure we have backup
schedules so that we're protecting our
data finally right most on the slide are
some of the more advanced concepts in
the database world setting up high
availability or replication for
scale-out making decisions about when to
failover when is the database unhealthy
and whether we should do that
automatically or manually all of this of
course gets tied together or plumbing
together with monitoring so that we can
understand how our stack is performing
when I think a cloud sequel I picture
this stack and I recognize the cloud
sequels job is to turn this stack into a
single API call or a few UI clicks so
that if you're a DevOps engineer or
developer with a single API call you can
spin up a very simple development
database or a much more complex
production database with high
availability and scale out for reads
what's not shown in this diagram is one
last important thing about cloud sequel
and that is that it's backed by cloud
sequels 24 by 7 SRE team Jason from real
massive points this out that because
cloud sequel is backed by an SRE team
whose job it is to automate and monitor
to keep the fleet healthy and then when
needed put hands on keyboards to bring
up an unhealthy database his team
worries less now about databases and
the pager so to speak and more about
other things in their technology stack
hopefully that gives you a little feel
for cloud sequel since this is a
performance talk let's get into scaling
cloud sequel I'm going to start with
some simple infrastructure concepts and
then we'll get into some real detailed
especially my sequel level conversation
scaling cloud sequel killing scaling
cloud sequel up to start with cloud
sequel starts very small if you're new
to cloud sequel cloud sequel instances
start at less than $10 a month they
scale up right now to 64 CPU cores and
more than 400 gigabytes of RAM these
numbers change over time when we present
again next year these numbers will be
larger they were smaller last year so
expect more cores more ram etc over time
I think scaling up with respect to CPUs
and RAM is pretty straightforward what's
a little less intuitive is how you scale
storage performance in cloud sequel and
generally in Google Cloud when you're
scaling when you're thinking about
scaling performance of storage in Google
Cloud note that you scale by increasing
capacity and cloud sequel as you see in
the small screenshot here includes a
performance calculator that shows how
much storage performance will be
delivered to your instance based on a
few factors how many CPU cores you've
selected and the capacity of storage you
are allocating to cloud sequel what I'll
note here is that as you increase
capacity we deliver more I ops and as
you can see by the calculator we're only
delivering about half of the I apps or
so that we could for this instance based
on the amount of capacity that we've
selected last thing you'll notice is
that managing the mundane that I talked
about earlier where the simple checkbox
here tells cloud sequel watch my storage
capacity if I'm getting too close to
filling up my disk grow it for me and do
it on the fly do it without taking my
database down so I think it's a great
way to point out not only how to scale
up but also some of managing the mundane
oK you've scaled up your cloud sequel
instance and at some point your workload
is so heavy that you're not able to
continue to burden this single instance
and it's time to scale out cloud sequel
makes scaling out easy in that again
with a few API calls or UI clicks you
can add replication and read replicas so
that in this common configuration we can
start to send expensive read queries
maybe we're running reports
Friday or we're using some reporting
tool you can send those to a replica
rather than pointing those at the
primary instanced which is already under
right load that way the primary instance
can focus on writes and reads go
elsewhere on to your replicas just by
show of hands here how many of you are
familiar with the difference between my
sequel's semi synchronous replication
and my sequels asynchronous replication
okay a handful of people a number at
number didn't raise their hand so I'll
give you the one minute overview semi
synchronous replication requires that a
primary instance and a standby instance
of replicas both write a transaction
before that transaction is acknowledged
to the application so an application
says here's my transaction to the
primary instance the primary instance
when replicated using semi synchronous
replication commits that transaction
itself and it waits for the replicas to
acknowledge that it's written the
transaction to a relay log
the replica doesn't have to actually
commit the transaction to data files as
long as it's written to a relay log the
replica will let the master that the
primary instance know okay I've got it
and the primary instance then goes back
to the application and says okay I'm
ready for your next transaction this has
I think two important characteristics
one is that in the event of a failover
we know that both our primary and
standby instants have the data we're not
going to lose data on a failover and for
that reason cloud sequel employs it as
the only way we replicate for a failover
replica the only way we replicate for
high availability the second
characteristic is performance overhead
right this is obvious we're sending it
right not only to the primary instance
but also to this secondary or standby
instance and we're waiting for both to
say okay I've got it before we left the
application right another transaction
this differs from a synchronous
replication in that in a synchronous
replication the primary instance will
happily continue to take transaction
after transaction without waiting for
the replicas to tell it okay I've got it
as well in this way you can have a
replica that doesn't have the very
latest transactions that the primary
instance has cloud sequel uses
asynchronous replication only for read
replicas these are your scale-out read
replicas
and for failover we're using semi
synchronous so we can guarantee we don't
lose data when we failover we also with
a failover replica ensure that we put it
in a separate zone a separate failure
domain if you will within a region so
that we have higher fault tolerance with
a read replica or for read scale out
where we're using asynchronous we let
you put those anywhere you want and
again we don't use them for failover so
what you see in this diagram is a very
common configuration I have a high
availability configuration I have semi
synchronous replication between my
primary instance in my failover replicas
and I've also added an asynchronous read
replica for read scale out so I'm moving
read load off of my primary instance so
that they can focus on write load and
this is what we're talking about when we
talk about cloud sequel scaling out now
an important note here is that while
cloud sequel makes all of this an API
call and makes scaling up and scaling
out easy it doesn't tell you when to
scale and that's important because it
still requires you to know your database
numbers what you see in this screenshot
is cloud sequel showing you a basic set
of metrics in the cloud console in
addition to those metrics we in cloud
sequel enable the nodb metrics table I
encourage you to get to know that table
it contains a wealth of performance
information about my sequel and will
help you make decisions about when to
scale up and when to eventually scale
out with that in mind let's take a look
back and I'll ask Stanley to take us
back to next 2017 and talk to us about
what's changed since then let me
actually take that back from you and
live first yeah if we have trouble with
the advancing we'll move it back over
here okay okay so let's take a look at
the classical performance we don't need
the pointers oh okay I've just waved my
hands there so so let's take a look at
the classical performance in 2017 what's
shown here is a typical assist bench
TP run or we run is a step load and kind
of test with each step doubling the load
of the previous step we started with one
test thread and then two then four then
eight and then all the way to 512
what sprouted here is an EPS transaction
per second and each step runs for about
20 minutes and for every second of those
20 minutes we collect the TPS data and
then profit here so this is you're going
to see a number of this kind of graph
throughout the presentation this is our
standard way of benchmarking and the
plotting results the benefit of this is
you will be able to see a lot of
variability so at this 20 minutes run
because every second of the data is
displayed on this chart so what you see
here is the red line is our performance
in February 2017 and the green lines of
performance in August 2017 and there are
two main reasons for this kind of
improvement or one is whether some level
of data base and especially in OD beat
Union to stabilize the performance of
data base and to allow the underlying
storage performance improvement to show
up at the data base layer the second
fundamental reason for this kind of
improvement is because of persistent
disk has made a lot of performance
improvements in both latency and
throughput remember that and clásico is
built on top of Google cloud platform
and uses persistent disk as an
underlying storage foundation and you
can see similar graph for the classical
post quest performance and this one is
for postcards HJ and the blue line is
February 2017 and the green line is
November 2017 and for similar reason and
we are seeing about 2x improvement in
our end performance and so then you
might wonder what about 2018 and this
data for 2017 one year ago and what
about now and actually I encourage you
guys to find out by yourself please feel
free to take pictures of this slide
because there's some information here so
I want to I really really want to bring
up
attention is the tool called Perth get
bench marker and so basically we decided
to open source all of our benchmarking
code not just database but also compute
storage and everything into a tool
called perf get bench marker and it's
available on github for the database
related one it's called manager relation
or dvd why that would be the starting
point and the fundamental reason we want
to open sourced our benchmarking tool is
to be purely open and transparent so you
get to see exactly what we are
benchmarking as you get to either code
you get to see how we set up the
framework you get to see what kind of
parameters were passing through the
tools you get to see what kind of tools
we use and we actually calls into this
bench and PG bench when doing this kind
of benchmarking so there is a benefit of
using perfect a benchmark is you can use
exactly the same two insane methodology
on other providers and find out the
numbers by yourself and make your
judgement so I will connect our
canonical test configuration when you
decide to try the perfectly benchmark
and to our canonical test configuration
is basically we always try to make sure
the data set is large so it's 5 X ran
and we use Angwin standard 16 and we
always try to fully provision the
underlying storage which there should be
one point seven terabytes for PDR safety
and for the best performance possible
and then we place the test client in the
same zone as the database and we run
each load step for long enough so we can
to observe the variability so next slide
and then besides the benchmarking tools
and we open sourced we also published
our tuning parameters and again please
feel free to take pictures here and
there's a tiny URL to the lower part
lower right part of the presentation and
it shows the number of nodb flags we
tuned to achieve the effect on the left
hand side as you can see the performance
effect of the left-hand side is more
stable more consistent
and documentation also describes and
explains the justifications and reasons
for why we turn each of those flags so
next slide now looking ahead and what is
next what is so today we're gonna spend
quite a bit of our time in this
presentation talking about a problem we
want to tackle we have trying to tackle
in the last few months our quarters
actually the problem is about scaling
rights at a very high concurrency load
now high concurrency high is always in
the context of some definition so here
we target sis bench concurrency tested
at 512 so what's shown here is a eight
hour long run of this bench or LTP at
512 threads and as you can see the
database performance varies by at least
three X it can go as high as about 3,000
and drops down to 1,100 for the first
half of the test and then for the second
half of stance that drops down to about
a couple of hundred like 100 to 200 from
time to time so with this kind of
variability in database and you know for
many developers and the database work
begin like essentially useless because
first of all it's hard to the capacity
planning with this kind of performance
and second is that you know for those
deep dips of PBS and during the second
half of the test and it easily can
translate into time outs from the
application server so basically a
performance problem will turn into a
variability problem and the third one
there is you know if a database is a
important piece of a critical user
journey or user experience for example
populating some of the fields on the UI
or saving some temporary states as user
going through a set of dialogue or UI's
to complete something end to end then
this kind of performance will lead to
pretty bad overall user experience for
the application so then let's take a
look why that problem happens where
exactly is a problem
so what's plotted here is what we call a
we'll be flush like so for those of you
who have read into the nodb and the ways
inaudible handles rights basically each
rights when they when nodb processor
right and it writes the transaction to
the redo log and that's as soon as the
transaction is committed to the redo log
the transaction were because they're
successful
meanwhile the data page in memory will
be also be modified but the data picture
will be flushed asynchronous as a
back-end to the data file now what's
plotted here is called a flash lock that
is a difference in bytes between the
latest write that has been successful
committed to the redo log - the oldest
write that is in memory that still has
not been flushed to data file and the
flash lag is equal generally equals to
the size of the redo log now in general
most of the database
almost all database and especially
Mexico has a limit on the size of the
redo log because it's a real dog is too
large it will affect your crash recovery
time so when nodb sees a flash log or
the size of the redo log grows
approaching the limit by default isn't
around 80 to 82 percent of that limit
then that which is plotted as a red line
horizontal red line on this chart that
is when InnoDB welcome interest and what
they call a sink flush state what a sink
fresh state means that is when the flash
lag or the redo log size is at in this
case 820 mega and then when the next
mutation comes in in ODB will not
process a mutation but instead they were
going into it's in memory 30 page find
out the oldest 30 pages to flush
successfully flush and writes that
better page in to the data file first we
cleanse the corresponding space in redo
log then it will take that new mutation
so this forms a stop-and-go pattern in
the end PPS graph as we see and this is
the fundamental reason why you are
seeing this kind of performance
variability that going through the next
slide
we're gonna see how we're gonna control
the flashback so as you can see flash
lag is how much lag the 30 page
flash is behind the incoming mutation
rate so logically it seems very simple
if you want to control flash like you
just want to make sure that database can
flash 30 pages and then great but it's
higher than incoming right right
so there are two angles to tackle this
problem when there's if you stop
incoming writes you have zero writes
then you will not have have flash like
but that's not acceptable we want to
make sure that our instance can support
as higher incoming write write as
possible so the next angle to attack
this is to make sure the database can
flash 30 page as fast as possible so
there's a concept called in ODB double
right obviously if we disable double
write you basically cut the right load
and during 30 page by half essentially
doubling the rate the database can flash
the protocol now we're going to talk
more about what is inaudible all right
in the next time so for those of you who
have never heard of energy be double
right this is a quick refresh and it's
basically you know DB babble right
that's exactly what it means is that
will write write twice so when in ODB
wants to flash a 30 page it writes each
delivered twice sequentially first to
the table all right buffer then to the
actual place into the fire then why why
does it do that why does it have to do
that so it has to deal with the concept
code of town writes torrid is that a on
disk turritella page that is partly new
and part wrote it happens when the write
operation of a 16 KB data page was
interrupted in the middle of the run and
for any reason then when the tour ID
happens then the only way to recover for
Anton right is to take that back up that
data page found the double write buffer
and user to recover all right you cannot
use redo log to recover turn right at on
page because to replay redo log you have
to have the original old page in its
correct form to replace a redo log but
with the Tom page you have a page that
is some part in your sample old that you
simply cannot
your color unless you have a backup copy
of that page which is why inaudible has
to do double right so then the next
question go deeper a little bit step
deeper is how could a Tom page turn
right happen there are two major reasons
for town right to happen when is a disk
so any traditional disks generally do
not have atomic rights and they can
write at 512 by the sector size many
discs for KB physical product size even
if they support atomic writes that would
be at 4 KB boundary and for a 16 KB data
page that means that if it's anything
that fails during the 16 KB data page I
write only part of that might be written
to the disk that's the first reason
second reason is a physis now let's say
you have physical disks that you buy
special hardware that can support 16 KB
atomic writes the file system still has
to do some magic to make sure that the
rights are sent to disk at 16 KB align
the boundary so in general most of the
file system ext4 are those they have 4
KB as a data page size and even the
linux kernel has 4 k vs page size that
means files are only guaranteed to align
at 4 kb boundaries now if a fire that is
aligned only at 4 KB boundary but is not
aligned at 16 KB boundary then a 16 KB
right into that fire may actually spend
two physical blocks on disk which gonna
break atomicity again so next slide I'm
the solution we come up with to tackle
this problem to allow us to safely
disable in the DB devil right is to try
to achieve 16 KB atomic rights you know
a storage stack from the top to the
bottom
and to end so first are gonna introduce
these layers from bottom to the top
actually the first of all we have walk
to is very closely with the persistent
disk in to create a 16 KB physical
blocks are candy that will provide
physical block level right atomic City
so I want to call this because this is
very unique and special in TCP that
there are some prior arts in the
industry you have to purchase special
hardware
with GCP all you have to do is to press
the uparrow of your keyboard which as I
suppose you have typed in jihad before
and then add a new parameter called
physical block size equal to 16 KB enter
you have a special disk that's about 16
K the atomic writes so the next layer of
the stack that we worked on which pad
we'll talk a lot more than detail is we
configured and use a new innovative
feature in ext4 called big dialogue with
big airlock we forced filesystem
allocate and alive files at 16 table
boundary and the third one is that to
ensure that and Linux kernel Paula
clarify system do not split writes into
16 KB boundary we walked with our
container optimized OS team to introduce
extensive regression and qualification
tests and to ensure that when upstream
changes the kernel code and we catch
those and invariants that were broken
and wounded sure that the OSS serve does
not break right the fourth one that we
actually was a walked with our GCD
virtualization teams to make sure some
of the critical parameters in but i/o
layers are configured properly mainly
its max segment size and maxed sectors
KB and there has to be they have to be
certain in variance for the cannot own a
split writes into 16 KB power the last
one at the top level is that with ours
we have to compute in ODB two years of
all direct so with that I would like to
invite that on to stage to talk about
antenna after miles oh oh sorry there's
too much light here huh so I want to
show the effect of a disable interval
rights as you can see if you recall the
flashlight graph and the previously I
was hitting the red line consistently
this is with the 16 KB feature as you
can see we are able to effectively
suppress a fresh lag well below the red
line and the next slide is shows the GPS
result I'm showing here on the middle of
the chart is the t+ and runni exactly
same load a tower and 512 starts and
that the performance is generally pretty
stable and consistent and the lower
right corner was doing for Katie and
Alvarado
all right start its my mic on excellent
so before we continue the story of how
we're able to enable the 16k instance
feature I want to take a brief detour
and talk a little bit about container
optimized OS some of you may have heard
about container optimized OS also known
as CE OS because it's the preferred
recommended image for google kubernetes
engine it's basically a stripped-down
Linux operating system that has a
security hardened Colonel verified boot
and since its stripped-down it has you
know just the software you need so we
can minimize its attack surface since
it's based on the open source chromium
OS we have a very rapid release cycle
and that's important for two reasons
the first is we can get security fixes
out and into cos very rapidly and the
second is it will also allowed us to get
new features new innovations deployed
very rapidly and not only is it the
recommended image for kubernetes engine
we also use it as the basis for cloud
sequels virtual machines fine so that's
how we actually deployed the kernel
changes and some of the user space
changes we needed to support this
particular feature so just to review
what are the - there - kernel guarantees
that we have to be able to make in order
to make sure that 16k database pages
don't get partially written to the disk
in the case of some kind of instance
failure or hardware failure and the
first is that we need to make sure that
the database files are laid out in
logical chunks there are 16 kilobytes
what we call clusters and I'll talk more
about that on the next slide and then
the second thing we need to make sure is
that these i/o requests don't get broken
up into multiple requests since that
might lead
- torn right in a failure scenario so to
do accomplish the first thing we used a
file system feature called big Alec it
was originally developed to optimize
write patterns for a large-scale cluster
file systems such as Google's GFS and
what it does is it works around a
restriction in the Linux virtual machine
which does not allow the filesystem
block size to be larger than the page
size which on intel x86 architectures is
only 4k um and so therefore we can't
make the block size larger than 4k so
what we do instead is we introduce a new
concept called clusters and clusters are
composed of power of two number of 4k
blocks and data files get allocated in
units of clusters we still send the
rights out in 4k blocks but the file
system tracks them in 16k clusters and
this feature has been around for quite a
while it actually hit the mainline Linux
kernel in 2011 but it was only only had
been used for very restricted use cases
as I said the original use case of this
was for large-scale cluster file systems
and so when we looked at what we would
need to do in order to enable this
feature for use in cloud sequel there
were two things that we decided we had
to do but to make it be production ready
the first is that we had to add support
for online resizing this is so as your
database grows and you have a need to
store more data cloud sequel will make a
request to the persistent disk to grow
the size of the persistent disk and we
need to be able to grow the file system
to use that extra space for the expanded
persistent disk and then the second
thing we needed to do is we had to add
extensive regression testing to me
make sure that all of the new corner
cases that cloud sequel might use were
actually exercised in our regression
testing in the CLS kernel to make sure
that there weren't any problems because
even though this big aleck feature has
been around for a long time it's not a
very commonly used feature and so there
was the possibility that there were
corner cases that no one had noticed
might not have been working quite right
so for the second requirement of what we
needed to do we had to audit the Linux
i/o stack historically all operating
systems including Linux will merge
adjacent requests in order to make
things more efficient and then if there
are limitations in either the scuzzy
controller or the actual scuzzy disk it
might break requests in - in order to
deal with those limitations and we had
to make sure that each layer in the i/o
stack starting at the filesystem layer
to the Linux block layer to the Linux
scuzzy layer to the Verdi Oska Z driver
all did not do what they're allowed to
do historically which is to break
requests up to make sure that if they
did they only broke them at 16k
boundaries and so that required doing
extensive audit of all of those code
paths and after we did that we had to
ask ourselves the question so what if
future Linux kernels might make changes
in storage stack and all that auditing
work might no longer be valid for some
new upstream kernel and so what we did
is we added additional regression tests
that actually tested to make sure that
writes would never get broken up at
inconvenient boundaries and we added
that to our continuous testing regime
that we use as part of our build and
release process for the kernels for
container optimized OS and that's to
make sure that you know the this
guarantee that we've made after auditing
the code will continue to be
in future linux kernel's and so the main
thing the final point I want to make
here is that this will effort required
collaboration across a large number of
teams at Google the cloud sequel team
the container optimized OS team the
persistent disk team and the GCE
virtualization team we all work together
in order to make this feature possible
and it's sort of a testimony to the sort
of things we can do when we take really
good people working at multiple layers
across the product to produce a feature
like this ok and back to breath that's a
great point Ted so to summarize a little
bit and talk about next steps we'll wrap
up here with just a few points when you
think about scaling cloud sequel start
simple as I mentioned scaling up is
intuitive except perhaps that scaling
storage is aligned with scaling its
capacity so note that capacity and
performance have a relationship in
Google cloud generally and in cloud
sequel look forward of course to larger
instance types and continued storage
performance improvements all the numbers
on the slides that we showed hopefully
will be outdated in some number of
months the commitment that cloud sequel
has in addition to being compatible
which I mentioned is your application
just worth the cloud sequel additionally
we also are committed to being open and
I think that shows up in a few ways
Stanly mentioned that our perf kit bench
marker is fully open source you see the
the tiny URL there we hosted on github
we encourage you to run it yourself it
should help you set up a test
environment should allow you to compare
cloud sequel against other database
services or a database that you're
running yourself and it allows you
because it's open source to change the
test parameters make them look more like
your work clothes the other thing that
Stanley pointed out is when we tune a
database we tune it not only for
ourselves but hopefully we tune it for
for everyone and we've posted for the
past couple years our tuning parameters
as cloud sequel on the third or on the
third bullet point you see on the slide
which is the bottom URL I encourage you
if you're not running cloud sequel on
GCP to start with our tuning parameters
if you're going to run my sequel of your
own accord
maybe on a compute engine VM and then
continued tuning from there our
parameters would give you better
performance than a default my sequel
installation will on compute engine and
we think it's a great starting point if
nothing else for you ted talked about
what it took to align teams within
Google so that we can safely turn off
double right buffer and produce what
we've called 16kb instances if you have
interest in seeing those for yourself in
cloud sequel please send an email to
this email address we have started an
active alpha program you're more than
welcome to join to see how right
optimization may benefit your workload
what you'll also see from the Google
teams is that we'll make these options
available to you if you're choosing to
run my sequel outside of cloud sequel as
well so if you're using container
optimized OS and a Stanley mentioned you
can configure persistent disk with 16
kilobyte block size you'll be able to
benefit from this yourself as long as
you stay within some of the parameters
as you can see there was a lot of work
from Linux kernel down through the
storage tag to make sure this is safe
but we're gonna do our best to make this
open like the rest of cloud sequel to
you as well I want to point out a couple
presentation pics worse on the really
kind of the first major day of the
conference I'm going to give you two
shameless plugs to start out first we
have a best practices for migrating to
cloud sequel session tomorrow afternoon
if you're interested in migrating a
workload to cloud sequel stop by and
take a look at this session it'll talk
about how to do that especially to my
sequel with low downtime just later this
afternoon
we're doing an introduction to cloud
sequel and kubernetes if you'd like to
learn more about kubernetes and how it
can work with cloud sequel take a look
at this session which is just after
today's session here and last on the
list is I ought went e5 which is what's
newest spanner if you haven't been
introduced to spanner I think this is a
good session to pick up what's new and
it'll of course give a bit of a product
overview on spanner as well with that on
behalf of Stanley and Ted I want to
thank you for spending the last 42
minutes with us and for bearing with a
few slide hiccups along the way we'd
love to open things up to your questions
and if we run at a time for questions
we'll ask that some of our cloud sequel
folks stay toward the front of the
so that you can catch up with us after
the session thank you everyone
[Music]
you
[Music]